we had the aftermath of aggression Oh
having another shutdown in paradise a
w.t.f rose ceremony and Dylan and Hannah
finally get a date I am Holland
this is your bachelor in paradise
episode 5 recap grab your glasses if
time for roses and rosy hi everybody i'm
lauren zima oh you guys something
specials happened we are in the presence
of something beautiful and now I don't
mean Dylan's undying love for Hannah I'm
talking about cake bread our friends at
cake bread sent me some wine
you guys I once drank a Cakebread
Chardonnay on roses and Rosie and Lisan
and sent over a little more vino
including a Sauvignon Blanc which I have
not tried this is something I've never
done in roses and Rose day before I've
never drank a Sauvignon Blanc on the
show before haha this is out of my realm
this is new for me but you know what
it's going down in Paradise so let's try
something new throw spaghetti at the
wall and see what sticks you know what
I'm saying and luckily it's coming from
a trusted brand Cakebread their wines
amazing we thank them again and here we
go that was a heavy port so we're back
with the fights yes we were left last we
got a to be continued and things
continue between Jordan and Christian
did you guys have to rewind this fight
scene I was winding and returning and
rewinding and returning because I was
trying to figure out exactly what
happened who was really the culprit who
really got things going I still can't
tell it's hard to know who the aggressor
is when a pinata is involved
[Music]
it was a really brief back and forth and
Jordan picked Christian up and throw him
if I'm being honest didn't know Jordan
had an enemy I didn't know I'm not
endorsing it I'm not supporting it but
he physically supported Christian and he
threw him I just I didn't know Jordan
was that what did the guys say yoked I
mean who do you guys think was
responsible for the fight if anyone oh
everybody seemed confused drink every
time someone said what's happening to
the ground now Jordans chill he walks
away Christians not he runs at him and
Christians fast Blake and Will's are
like that was too much from Jordan goes
too much he went over the top rope
Jordan took things over the top you
think Jordan went over the top I haven't
seen a physical fight like that at
Paradise that was aggressive and there's
that word you know aggression the word
that Nicole had been saying she wanted
more of from clay last week well now
Nicole's like maybe I shouldn't have
been so into that it's like yeah we just
need a different word
I think assertive assertive works
I am absolutely fine yeah I apologize so
you know this show was dealt with
scandal in the past and they're gonna
move on from this fast Chris Harrison
and other producers sit down Jordan they
sit down Christian they tell them both
we have a zero-tolerance policy and they
send the poem and Jordan Christian to
their credit both took it well took it
in stride what do you guys think fair
I'm so glad like you're still you're
absurd I got these crazy dates leaving
house for days on it and not shockingly
after all isn't it Cole's like clay clay
clay okay every guy that's coming here
is basically fond over Hannah and she
seems like super innocent but she's not
innocent in any of this back to
everybody else and everyone keeps saying
Hannah isn't innocent
what is her crime I need someone to tell
me what is her crime you know my mom
always wanted to take my vitamins and
right now I'm taking a multivitamin
tonight I need to figure out whether I
need to take a little bit more about M&B
or vitamin D now I'm trying Sauvignon
Blanc but I'm not gonna hide that from
Rosie I'm gonna let Chardonnay know
about it - Hannah's doing a wine flight
of sorts you know don't sleep but you
know while hannah is tasting dylan is
digging and he says that hannah is the
most beautiful girl he's ever seen right
over there
literally the most beautiful girl we see
my entire life I literally just stare at
her all day
Dylan is all in you know dill all in
drink every time someone or Dylan
himself says he's smitten
you're very Smith yeah very special
bitten do it
and God while Hannah's trying the guys
the guys are trying for Hannah drink for
every romantic gesture made for Hannah
any like picnics
[Music]
if we're being honest the mariachi band
was just so Blake could do that swing
dancing thing again I want to say at
least there's music this time but I
didn't want to say that okay you know
did anybody get Hannah a glass of wine
that's what I would have done
Micah can I say something early yeah and
then oh my god you guys a tearful self
exit our girl on Jenka says this isn't
working for her and she out I can't give
out a rose anyone tonight
and I'm really sorry should she have
left I don't get why you leave if you
have the power at the rose ceremony you
don't know who might show up on the
beach might be somebody good for you and
drink every time Will's is the voice of
the people this episode he says what up
night John Paul jack
by the way Taoiseach gives her rose to
John Paul Jones and I just love how much
he is John Paul Jones invitations
everything I look for in a wife
Taoiseach is like the hottest girl I
have ever talked to you drink for every
big moment at the rose ceremony Hannah
gave her rose to Dylan but she did not
choose Blake I didn't think she would
did you
that would have been wild what was great
is that you know Dylan's been struggling
so much but he got a little moment he
got the rose
and he went stood right next to Blake
where on that rose and Blake at that
face like
Christina gave him a rose he's not going
anywhere
Will's again the voice of the people
shaking his head like white watch why
watch know what I know you have not had
a plan I do sunshine paradise but I was
later the first
Christina says she thinks Blake's a good
person but he deserves another chance I
have to say you know Dean's here on this
Beach
and remember it was just a year ago on
this exact same show that Dean was the
mayor of Ville and his mustache
represents literal and figurative growth
so I think we have to admit there's hope
for Blake but Tim Blake deserve a second
I mean I'm sorry seventy second chance
let me know in the comments below
cam is gone Kevin is gone Will's is gone
there's none of this surprising no
bright I mean sure that tracks
oh my god Dylan just said he's keeping
the Roseanne I gave him for the rest of
his life okay I defended Dylan on
Twitter because some people are saying
Dylan is too obsessive and too clingy
and I think sometimes it's hard for guys
like we want them to be totally focused
on us but then we get upset when they
are welcome to your personal house but
then wait a minute
sometimes Kristina's a secret savage she
just told Blake welcome to your personal
hell welcome to your personal house did
she give him the rose just so that he
had to watch Hanna and Dylan get it on
it
Christie and then Blake is just laying
and he's looking blankly Blake is blank
but he does have a book and this was
interesting to me I actually recently
tweeted that they don't have books and
TV and stuff in Paradise I guess they
have books I was wrong drink for me
being wrong we have a new arrival capes
Len is here hey Lynn is here I don't
really remember who Caitlin is Caitlin
is the new Christian because we don't
know who Caitlin is I think she was on
cult Lou's season and that she had like
one really awkward self-involved
conversation with him and then he sent
her home I'm terrified of someone
walking on his beach and sinking away
and I know the possibilities that are
extremely high I'm aware of who he is in
his reputation in his past okay Dean do
you want to chat oh by the way cheers to
Caitlyn for being smart about Dean she's
like I'm taking things slow cuz I know
Dean's mo mm-hm
I'm also drink every time Dylan is
holding on to Hannah literally that's
all Blake how do you feel about taking
off for the day sounds great not
shockingly Caitlin takes Blake on the
dates
I guess we're you know still getting
into Blake and then until it kind of
makes this joke like hope they didn't
hook up but stagecoach I'm sure Blake
was probably damning Kailyn for the show
hopefully she didn't go to stagecoach
and then oh my god we learned that they
did hey we met a stagecoach nothing
happens
[Music]
right
Blake's like I'm trying to keep an open
mind I'm trying to keep an open mind you
know saying he's physically emotionally
exhausted okay well Blake yeah cuz
you've been you've been running on the
treadmill of thoughts and feelings
haven't you so far paradise even pretty
brutal for me honestly like you're top
to bottom this is where you step off the
treadmill and you meditate and you focus
on yourself you actually won't take a
yoga class Oh a sexy yoga class with
another woman you want to go ahead and
keep doing this dating thing seems right
yeah interestingly Blake says he hates
the word settle down I hate the word but
settle down really why thought you were
here to find love Blake that's what you
told us
also not a word it's a term maybe
actually having a little bit of fun down
here that would be very very nice
yeah nanny says he just wants to finally
have a little fun down in paradise what
do you want Blake and they're making out
god this shows a comedy Blake's trying
to justify his behavior and he's like
I'm a good guy did he like kill anybody
and I didn't cheat or any of that when
your defense is not being a murderer
that's rough yeah it's hard to see and
in doing there's no talking about Blake
being sad over Hannah and Dylan but I
wrote down honestly I zoned out during
that that's not good they're like dating
right in front of your girl
[Applause]
tonight's my first real day with Hannah
and I'm excited and then Hannah and
Dylan finally go on a date and oh my
gosh we got the moment we've been
waiting for Hannah makes her decision I
am Colin and she tells him I am all in
Dan'l and a drink for that but then
really drink for this I did not come to
spend us I'm gonna do Dylan says what is
possibly the best line in bachelor in
paradise history he tells her I didn't
just come here for the summer with you
I came press has been everything after
it tell her I came here for all the
seasons of life with you he didn't
actually say the seasons think I just
added that in but I think it makes it
even better
scripting that's been an issue on the
season of Paradise has met people
allegedly scripting their storylines
what are these things are getting to
schemee are people planning too much
before they head into the show we have
some exclusive reporting on all of the
crap that went down between Demi and
Tanner head over to eat a line after
that shameless blood okay
JP Taoiseach are hanging out and I don't
even know what happened in their
conversation but it was great Teesha
Paul Jones and then you know Demi is
confused I just feel guilty that there's
a woman that I'm still thinking about
and she talks about being confused she
is having feelings for Derek but she is
still thinking about this woman she was
dating before she left for the show now
there has been talk about whether Demi
headed into paradise with a plan to just
be with this woman all along Tanner
Tolbert went on Twitter and spoke to et
saying that he'd heard this from
multiple people in bachelor nations
saying that he wants to maintain the
integrity of paradise where he met and
fell in love with Jade and that Demi was
scheming and scripted Demi is denied
these allegations
Tanner compared her to Jed which I
didn't think was fair because no one's
coming forward as they did with Jed
saying that Demi like lied about
everything nobody's saying that the
relationship that I had had back home is
a lot more serious and still means a lot
to me but Demi
interestingly though Demi does tell
Hannah that things with Christian are
actually a lot more serious then Demi
goes and talks to Derek and tells him
that she downplayed her feelings for
Christian - out playing it a little bit
I really really think about her a lot
and I have so many
her okay and then Derek isn't giving up
Mike I'm not get enough now he still
wants to pursuit Demi I feel like you
should give up don't you think Derek and
Dylan you know they will just not give
up on these beautiful blondes worked out
for Dylan and we end things with Demi
wanting to talk to Chris Harrison what's
gonna happen we've seen from the
trailers that Demi's gal shows up in
Paradise we know that so I'm guessing
we're gonna get that love you guys so
much thank you again cake bread that's
all I have to say we will be back with
another episode based on Tuesday night's
episode of bachelor in paradise so
follow along i'm on instagram cameo but
I'm not at stagecoach babe this is your
bachelor in paradise episode what
episode is it five that's the way to
somebody's heart you know I'm sorry take
bread we're in a relationship now Oh
Wyatt ASMR
so sue okay I got a stop
[Music]